Wow another reddit video that's so cool
Felix thank you
actually I've been traveling for a few
days now I'm in Canada and I'll be back
very soon but I had to work ahead so you
should be thankful anyway I hope you
still enjoy this video just wanted to
clarify why there's been the same I
actually really for coming back and
working on Minecraft and stuff like that
but until then Johnny
bye-bye okay kids describe color to a
blind person of you ever saw a color of
a blueberry I've never seen anything
ever that's the whole point
kids are freaking stupid what's up
gamers it's time to fully understand
just how stupid kids are and not only
are they stupid they are also weak I
challenge any child to a fight today we
are reviewing kids are freaking stupid
I'm wearing glasses so I'm probably
twice as smart as a child by default
when I was six I named my animal
crossing character sex and couldn't
change it back so panicked went outside
the next day and smashed the game card
with a head I have lived with this my
whole life
oh god how do I delete it I must destroy
the evidence right now get the hammer I
can just imagine like a rainy night
Thunder take out your animal crossing'
cartridge and you smash it to the ground
because no one can know this is one of
the best clips of all coding so much
chaos in ten seconds this stuff every
face in this is absolutely ten out of
ten it's so good
this clip is one of the greatest clips
online I have this theory and I've been
talking about this for a long time and
if you follow me as well you know all
right I think it's time for me to start
getting my opinions out there because I
am going for president in 2020 and my
idea is basically picture Hunger Games
but you can't just have a bunch of
people there that's immoral and
unethical just have kids instead have
kids every child that way you never have
to see a child that way only the good
children will survive and will create a
society of strong people I realized this
comes across as a little too generous
kids are great I love kids they're
awesome I just remember it that when I
got my first dog I was seven and he was
1/7 in dog years and I cried when he
turned 2 because I didn't think a
14-year old dog oh no my dog is too cool
to be with me now I'm trying to think
what stupid ideas I had as a child but I
can't think of any I was just I was just
big brain since the womb I mean I yes I
did think the action mang figurine came
with a real-life surfboard and harpoon
okay that's not my fault that's false
advertising yes I thought that action
meant police uniform came with the
police uniform is that so crazy and a
dog with an epic leash
I got light too it's not my fault I was
failed as a child
keep your toddler busy by letting them
paint the fence with me so good oh I
take back my idea by valuing I I want I
want to have my own kid so I can
terrorize it by doing these things oh my
god I look forward to this so much this
reminds me my parents would always force
me to shovel snow outside our staircase
we had a staircase outside a house it
wasn't our staircase it was the public
staircase but my mom was like oh if we
don't shovel the snow and an old lady
falls and dies then we can go to jail
because we're liable and I'm like oh god
I have to shovel the snow because I
don't want those to go to prison stupid
old ladies
I was tricked I was tricked to shovel
snow life in Sweden is not easy I'm
sorry feel free to share your stories I
want to hear when my brother was like
nine he said get the f sensor G instead
of the gift bag all right seeing this on
road like so they ban him and he cried
that's some hard-ass crying I had to
work overnight last night and while
taking a nap today I was vandalized I
have a picture and I have detained the
two suspects but one is not cooperating
the only one who can speak blames it on
the foreleg suspect wears no hands to
pull such a stunt
thanks to my neighbor for pointing out
that I have a marker all over my face
when I took the four-legged suspect for
a walk before I realized that I was
vandalized well it seems like kids one
parent zero you got played fool
imagine being outsmarted by a child
daughter didn't want son scream so I put
her outside and yell son get her and now
she's flipping oh yes well I guess you
know what I'll live mate I fell for the
whole carrot meme write that if you eat
a carrot you can see well in the dark
but I never ate the carrots anyway so it
doesn't matter oh my god now I remember
oh god it's all coming to me I love
chicken as a child so a way my mom would
make me eat food was she would tell me
everything is chicken I was like oh what
is this meat and my mom is like oh it's
chicken you love chicken right but he
got to a point where she just said
everything was chicken
I remember pointing at an onion and I
was like mom what is this I don't like
this this tastes bad and she my mom was
like no that's a chicken I'm like
no it isn't and that's when I realize
parents are freaking liars
same with Santa Claus goddamn it's
unethical to lie to children I feel like
there's so many things that you were
like that has there ever been
I'm curious has ever been anything you
were taught as a child and you just
don't question it for like 10 years and
then you're and then you're about to
tell someone something I'm like actually
that onion is a chicken and then you
realize oh god it's unethical to lie to
children my sister just had a baby she
brought in her home today and my other
niece was so pissed she packed up all
her stuff and tried to leave fine
go just go everyone has stories of them
running away right everyone has a story
oh I ran away and no one noticed so I
came back never ran away because I'm f
ik I'm smarter than that I know I would
die bedtime was half an hour ago my
six-year-old just walked out bleary-eyed
asked his father if a duck is a predator
some things are too important to go to
bed without knowing that's fair
you know at least I can appreciate a
child that question things incompetent
child look at a cupid what all the look
of embarrassin that's beautiful my dad
only took me to one soccer game I
remember it very clearly that no one is
scored the entire match no one made it
and it made a point until the end and
everyone stood up including me except my
dad and my dad looked at me and with
disappointment and said that was the
other team that scored Felix and after
that we never went to another ball game
Oh God oh no wait this is Mina was this
idiot child no that can't be right that
can't be right
kids are stupid not me I'm wearing
glasses you can't be mad at kids for ask
Oh delicious substance it's so delicious
like like like like enter car purified
30% off try Athenee flavor
it'll make your mouth taste like heaven
causing of three-year-olds meltdown this
morning banana to small
bananas slightly squashed honey on
porridge doesn't sufficiently resemble a
swimming-pool sister had her first we
before his third doesn't want scooter
does want scooter something to do with
sleeps okay this is it when the kids are
acting like this they've gone too far
and you need to send them to the island
it needs a better name maybe like Darwin
Island that's where they all fight it
out they'll be like a Call of Duty
basically there will be kill streaks
when you beat all the children you get
the choice of either continuing or go
back to society and I think a pretty
good anime can be based around the
concept as well so if anyone wants to if
I have any anime makers watching this
feel free to contact me oh my god he has
been very very picky lately
but loves Taco Bell so I made a homemade
meal and put it into a Taco Bell bag and
it actually worked
I would never fall for this
simple-minded treachery toddler daddy I
want toast me okay buddy here's some
toast toddler
I don't like butter on my toast flip
toast over to the dry side and hence it
back there you go toddler thanks daddy
yeah if you let your toddler control you
then I'm sorry you need to be sent to
the island as well oh that's a good idea
write that down that's a really good
idea what's the most recent illogical
breakdown your toddler had he loved
being tickled so I was tickling him one
day he let out a huge fart and suddenly
started crying and screaming I asked him
why he's screaming and he replies with I
was saving that for later all right we
need a separate island for really smart
gifted children to make sure that these
kids can thrive in an environment where
society doesn't break it down for them
okay how dare you question why they were
saving apart don't say you want a Lego
tower building contest if you can't have
a Lowe's egg Oh kids are so dumb you
feeble child you thought you could beat
me in lego building contest I will beat
you in any challenges hmm I'll let you
pick the category
I remember the first time you looked at
porn online it was so confusing because
you knew your pants knew what sites you
access you didn't know how they knew
what size you went on so it was
terrifying to like go to a porn website
so once you did I remember I went
through Pamela Anderson calm or
something like that and I was like I
need to savor this I already explained
this sir but now I already gotten far
enough in it I don't know how my parents
can know this so I need to savor this
the fact that I'm going on break ingush
barrier by going to this website so I
need to savor it so I printed the photos
like the genius I am I'm like oh this
way I don't have to keep going back to
this website and risk getting caught but
then I had a genius epiphany that that's
not a good idea that as tangible
evidence okay I should just cancel these
prints and I cancelled the prints and
went on with my day
to summarize the story they still
printed at a later time when my dad was
at the printer and he showed me the
pictures and it was epic I'm becoming an
actual boomer like saying the same
stories twice now my son trying to get
back down from washing his hands just
hang in there helpless so I decided to
take a photo and humiliate him online
this is good parenting and I appreciate
it I walk out a target to the scene of a
child laying motionless on the ground I
asked what was wrong and it had said
he's upset his gloves match his jacket
that's awesome
the child should be stupid send him to
the ranch Oh we'll call it the ranch
that makes sense
one time my uncle put a wig on my
cousin's head and told him it was
permanent yes
lions can hunt and kill their own food
by the time they're three months old my
three year old couldn't find her
lunchbox and it was in her other hand
this is what I mean if evolution is real
then why are kids so dumb this is why we
need the ranch okay you don't understand
my society if you vote for me we'll be a
prosperous nation it will be a
semi-autonomous state and the ranch can
bring up a lot of revenue if we turn it
into an anime I'm just saying
opens bottle of bleach nephew
how did you open it I tried but it
didn't open oh it's because it has a
child safety a lot children can't open
it
nephew looks at bottling amazement how
did it know I was a child
it's that bottle of programmed how can
bottle know what is the dumbest thing
you believed as a child I thought
Michael Jackson has to stop whatever
he's doing and sing when I play his CD
as a result I never played it at night
to give him some family time that is
actually nice and wholesome that's so
nice wait CDs are kind of old though how
old were the person who made this bet
you kids don't know what I catch that
player is God I'm an actual boomer this
kid asked me for some skittles but I had
just finished them so he stared at me
like this didn't I how can you do this
but why why you eat them all I would
just say yeah just let me finish them
first and eat them slowly in front of
him mom I just wanted to tell you that
Mother's date wouldn't be possible
without me I'll be waiting for my
present in the living room love Joshua
Joshua is a child with great potential
and he will not go to the ranch he will
go to the special school of gifted
people Joshua another gifted child I see
my first grade students were asked to
write letters to the local nursing home
and times almost up why is there such a
difference between the gifted chat seat
my theory is perfect this is gonna go
great
he made iron man out of costume this
would be my reaction either way if I met
him I used to think this movie was
live-action and the people who lived in
Europe look like this this is true all
Europeans look like that I'm actually
CGI
I'm always a little annoyed with parents
when kids are really scared of dogs is
that it's a weird thing to say but if
I'm wrong feel free to tell me but I'm
always like dude have you not taught
your child my dogs are safe like at
least my pugs I don't know it's like
Edgar comes up to a child and they're
like I don't like Jesus Christ teach
your kid how to interact with dogs it
ain't that hard
I still see adults
getting scared of dogs I mean I don't
want to shame people if they have fears
that's fine but it's just weird like
Edgar ran after him lady one time and
she started screaming like an adult
woman started screaming in genuine fear
out of Edgar the Swedish looking area
come here I feel like I need to show
just how stupid this dog looks so you
understand if this dog comes after you
like how can you be scared and I was
like it's okay he's friendly she was
like oh okay I usually just grab Edgar
and then I tell them to pet them it's
like I'm doing the job for the parents
maybe maybe the children isn't fault
maybe it's the parents being dumb dumbs
yes that's so good this guy this kid
will go to that the place of gifted
people Jackie you can't just white out a
question answer this kid will work for
the Chinese government one day oh my god
PewDiePie sucks read description I'm not
a PewDiePie hater I'm a bro but I'm a
new youtuber so I figure this would be a
good way to get views please understand
peace spots spend 2 1 4 you are going
places if I was ruler we would put you
in a special category of special
children attempting to cool down hot
chips put them in front of a fan this is
a special child alright guys I had a lot
of fun hope you guys enjoyed as well so
much like if you did I really appreciate
it if you want to support the channel
check out the merch and as always have
an epic day thank you
bye bye well you haven't tried to
personal a turd since me after 50
million outros much go just go it's
still relevant just